eyes of the British World Order and the
lessons for global power this hour-long
talk is moderated by Council on Foreign
Relations senior fellow Walter Russell
Mead well I'm glad you could all be here
tonight to welcome Neil Ferguson I'm
particularly glad it turns out that his
name is Neil and not as I was so often
hearing in Washington Niall since I had
been presiding over a meeting and
calling him Neil for an entire hour I
thought oh my god I just offended him
but turns out no by sheer dumb luck I
was right it is Neil Ferguson who is one
of the brightest and most interesting
historians I think writing in Great
Britain today and luckily for all of us
he's been writing on a very timely and
topical subject which is to say he's
writing about Empires and although his
latest book Empire the rise and demise
of the British World Order and the
lessons for global power takes as its
explicit subject the British Empire at
more than a few places in this book you
can see that he's thinking and offering
advice to the American well as he would
call it an empire none of us ever would
and I've you know I find as I read Neil
I had the feeling that for a very long
time now we've had we've been very lucky
here in the new Rome and having so many
Greeks come over to tell us how we
should be running running our empire
there is a small part of me that thinks
well what happened to your empire by the
way that you know that there's some
lessons here or is maybe this the Fox
who lost his tail explaining to all the
other foxes it would be better to cut
yours off as well but actually Neil has
some very interesting points of view
some very good advice to give us and so
I'm very happy to welcome him tonight
and I'd like to start off with the first
question which is is the United States
the center of an empire is there really
such a thing as an American Empire in
your
you or what are the only truly amazing
thing to me is that Americans don't
admit this and it in many ways this I
think is the first Empire in world
history based on a collective suspension
of disbelief on the part of the imperial
power itself now this could be the basis
for a new and uncanny form of Imperial
strength after all if you don't even
admit you have an empire quite
potentially you could you could extend
an empire and further than those who
vertically do it but my instincts about
this is that if it looks like a duck and
it quacks like a duck then there's a
fairly good chance that it is a dark and
I thought I would L astray at this point
with a little quotation and I'd like to
invite you to speculate as to when this
document was written I'll be very brief
our armies do not come into your cities
and lands as conquerors or enemies but
as liberators it is not the wish of our
government to impose upon you alien
institutions it is our wish that you
should prosper even as in the past when
your lands were fertile when your
ancestors gave to the world literature
science and art and when Baghdad City
was one of the wonders of the world it
is our hope that the aspirations of your
philosophers and writers shall be
realized and that once again the people
of Baghdad shall flourish enjoying their
wealth and substance under institutions
which are in consonance with their
sacred laws and their ideals now if that
sounds familiar to you then I have
vishakan store because that wasn't
President Bush in an uncannily eloquent
moment
it wasn't the first draft of his address
to the Iraqi people that got torn up
when when dub you actually read read it
through that was general F s mod in
April 1917 issuing a proclamation to the
people of Baghdad following a lightning
military campaign by British forces that
had swept up from cooked to Baghdad and
placed Mesopotamia under British rule
which it would remain under on-and-off
indirectly and directly for the better
part of 41 years so the key point I'd
like to suggest is that this is not the
first Anglophone Empire to invade let us
say Iraq in the name of the liberation
of the people of Iraq even the if you
like denial that an invasion is an
invasion that an occupation is an
occupation this denial is something that
the British long ago perfected as part
of the rhetoric of liberal Empire and my
sense is that one very strong argument
in favor of Americans reading my book is
that they will begin to recognize what
Heather - they have so brilliantly
avoided admitting to themselves namely
the true extent of the resemblance
between the first and the second great
Anglophone empires it's obvious of
course to any Britain why Americans are
in denial about the fact that they are
an empire it was I think obvious to
Reinhold Niebuhr when he pointed out at
the end of the Second World War that the
Republic now it really had become an
empire this insight by the way is
entirely familiar to all Europeans and
only remarkable to Americans the point
of course is that and I try to show this
in the book this country's creation myth
is that of an anti Imperial particularly
anti British imperial Republic and it's
extremely hard when you're on your high
schools teach the history of American
independence as a war of liberation
against an evil empire to come to terms
with the terrible reality a that that
was a
war not a war of independence a war
within a greater British speaking
English speaking British Empire and
secondly to come to terms with the fact
that this Republic almost from it's very
inception began to behave like another
British Empire think of the expansion of
the frontier on the North American land
mass itself think only of the annexation
of the Republic of Texas interestingly
where your president himself comes from
the process of imperial expansion has
almost been unceasing in American
history since 1898 when the how I was
added and the Philippines were
temporarily added to the American Empire
it's been a sustained tale of expansion
sporadic occasionally unsuccessful but
expansion into territory military
interventions in sovereign states what
is happening at the moment is only novel
it seems to me in one respect so far
it's only novel in that there are
elements within the present American
administration that more or less admit
that this is an imperial project I can
think of at least one senior figure in
the defense department who only what 10
years ago spoke the unspeakable when
Paul Wolfowitz said what many people
were thinking in the intellectual
circles around that it was time to get
real about empire that cost him a
temporary career setback but it seems to
me the really significant thing at the
moment is not what's happening
interventions in sovereign states Bill
Clinton did it in the case of Yugoslavia
without even pretending to get a UN
resolution now what is not well now is
that some people in positions of power
in Washington are daring to admit to
themselves and indeed to others that
this is an imperial project and my sense
is that coming out of denial may
actually be a healthy rather than
unhealthy development as it usually is
in cases of psychological difficulty
well the scholar in me is forced to
agree that there's a good deal of truth
in what you say and the Jacksonian my
inner Jacksonian is probably is saying
at this point well the difference
between that British proclamation and
the American ones is that the British
rely we really are they're they with
their typical treachery we're lying but
we have liberated Iraq well I just hope
Walter that you'll like actually but
also if if we do say that we don't have
an empire even as we've grown into the
most powerful state perhaps in the
history of the world here again I think
it's just an example of us learning from
the British model the British you say oh
the Empire yes we acquired it in a fit
of absence of mind and we've just gone
one little step towards the empire we
haven't acquired it at all it's it's in
a sense that it is it is essential to
the project of liberal Empire that it
not speak its name and that the more in
the sense you talk about your empire the
more people begin to wonder well which
is more important the liberal or the
Imperial side of it so one could argue
if one we're disposed that way to say
that that to start talking about Empire
and thinking about the strategy of
empire this is actually a point you make
in in your book about how around the
turn of the twentieth century you had
this whole raft of strategists of Empire
was no longer something you took for
granted but had to build and defend that
could be a sign of weakness in turn of
the tide an increased awareness of the
phenomena hopefully not
why did the British Empire fall well
that's a very good question because
there are many many misapprehensions on
this subject I can think of two offhand
that might deter Americans from
embracing their existing Imperial role
the first of course is the idea that
that the Empire was overthrown by by
nationalist movements by resistance
movements following as it were the
example of Mel Gibson in the patriot
struggling against the
the red-coated Nazis and your words not
ours an Australian film was worse still
the second argument which might be made
and has been made in the huge literature
is that the Empire ultimately weakened
Britain's economic development and was
one of the reasons for Britain's
industrial decline an argument which of
course Paul Kennedy made very popular in
the late 1980s with his extraordinary
powerful and important book the rise and
fall of the great powers which drew an
explicit parallel if you remember
between the alleged
overstretch of Reagan's United States
and the overstretch of the award Ian
Empire at the turn of the century now
what I try to argue in the book is that
to understand the decline and fall of
the British Empire you have to recognize
that there really wasn't any decline
that was just a fall and the Empire went
from Zenith to collapse with
breathtaking speed for two very simple
reasons but very different reasons from
those conventionally claimed in the
literature the first of these reasons
was that the British failed to deter the
biggest threat to their long-term
dominance posed by a rival Empire and
that rival Empire was the German Empire
there were two colossal failures of
deterrence which culminated in 1914 and
in 1939 with the outbreak of hostilities
in Europe between Britain and Germany
the cost of these Wars was the principal
reason for the fall of the British
Empire and particularly the bankrupting
cost of the second world war and I think
it's very clear that these wars were
results of failures of policy avoidable
failures I argued in the book the pity
of war which I remember discussing with
Paul Kennedy here at the council and a
wonderful occasion some of you may have
been present at argued there that in
1914 Britain's liberal government had
arrived at a completely contradictory
position was to prove fatal to Britain's
long-term imperial health and the
position
was that in the event of a continental
war in Europe and in the event of a bid
by Germany to European hegemony Britain
would intervene on the side of France
and indeed on the side of Russia this
was a dramatic change in British foreign
policy the problem was that the Liberals
failed to will the means the means would
have involved introducing conscription
and creating a land army equal to the
challenge posed by the by then
formidable German army and this failure
of policy this if you like paradoxical
policy proved extremely costly because
the Germans were not deterred by the
prospect of six or seven British
divisions in 1914 and then history
repeated itself in the 1930s with the
second colossal failure of deterrence on
the part of British policymakers so
reason number one for the decline of the
British Empire is the failure to deter
the principal challenge for global power
reason number two has a lot to do with
this country it was it seems to me one
of the great disasters of 20th century
history that Franklin Roosevelt
adopted as one of his warring following
his reluctant entry into World War two
the dismantling of the British Empire I
try to show in the book that Roosevelt
systematically pursued an anti British
Imperial policy from the very outset and
that his reasons for doing this were
profoundly wrongheaded you only have to
read the account of Roosevelt own routes
to one of the wartime conferences
touching down in Ghana looking at the
window seeing a mud hut and an African
and thinking and writing my god this is
what the British Empire has done as if
Ghana had been a flourishing prosperous
capitalist economy until the British
turned up Roosevelt's impressions of the
British Empire were classically
ill-informed they were typical it seems
to me of the the American anti-imperial
prejudiced and they informed his
campaign for a post-imperial declaw a
colonized world after 1945 something
that Churchill very quickly came to
realize something also
john maynard keynes came to understand
and anybody who wishes father
confirmation of my argument should read
Robert Skidelsky is brilliant Keynes
biography it was Keynes who said in the
course of the negotiations about war
finance in Washington negotiations he
abhorred he hated coming to America he
found the American politicians
insufferably rude because they used to
answer the phone when he was in full
flight and that's a warning to any of
you with cell phones to turn them off
because I'm a bit like Keynes in that
regard and and Keynes said that the
Americans were picking the eyes out of
the British Empire and in 1945 the eyes
were picked right out with the
suspension the immediate suspension of
lend-lease and the immediate bankruptcy
of the United Kingdom an American
foreign policy decision that did not
need to be taken one big question one
has to ask with the benefit of hindsight
actually without the benefit of
hindsight British colonial office
officials constantly asked it in the
1940s is this why did Roosevelt and his
advisors make a distinction between the
British Empire which they seemed to
abhor and the demise of which they were
eager to hasten and the russian empire
which they never ever advocated the
decolonization and why was this they
called it in the colonial office the
saltwater fallacy that an empire was
only an empire in the eyes of roosevelt
if there was salt water between the
metropolis and the colonies but because
the the russian empire was an entirely
land-based empire almost entirely
land-based empire somehow that didn't
count well maybe if you're a land-based
empire yourself which the united states
for most of its history has been that's
a straightforward little piece of
doublethink but it had fateful
consequences think over the history of
the Cold War think over the fundamental
decision that informed not only
Roosevelt but his successors policies to
prioritize a with relations in the
Roosevelt era with the Soviet Union be
good relations with nationalist
movements throwing off European colonial
empires think of the fateful year 1950
Fiasco of sewers which was of course a
blunder on the part of Eden never
listened to French strategic proposals
as even as Aiden faithfully did but in
the end it was one of those decisive
moments in the history of the Middle
East the decision the rupture between
Britain and the United States over the
future of the Middle East and the
fundamental decision to back the nassos
against the British was to have profound
ramifications not only in Egypt but in
Iraq two years later because it was in
1958 that the British bat Hashemite
dynasty was overthrown and Iraq's
Agony's properly can be said to have
begun interestingly the United States
intervened momentarily at that precise
moment there was a realization that this
might not have been such a smart idea
but the operation was not followed
through and the intervention was
effectively called off so you see the
decline and fall of the British Empire
has much more to do with other empires
the German Empire the Japanese which I
haven't mentioned and ultimately the
American Empire then it has to do with
insurgent nationalists the British found
them pretty easy to deal with but it's
pretty hard to cope with insurgents when
you've been declared bankrupt by the
United States which is in effect what
happened in 1945
well I'm feeling more and more wicked
here
well you if you admit to being a
Jacksonian you certainly should feel it
is interesting I think that Roosevelt's
anti British imperialism actually was
not only he and his term said I'm Dutch
was always roses point of view and this
is what Britain did to Holland in the
17th century and Roosevelt enjoyed doing
the same thing to the to the Brits sort
of giving them a taste of their own
medicine as it were but it was a I mean
III think there's there's more and more
of a historical consensus that yes the
British Empire didn't fall it was pushed
and it was pushed from behind more than
pulled down from the front and the
Americans and the Americans did it
Roosevelt did it Morgenthau did it Harry
Dexter white did it
but again the Democratic Party probably
couldn't have held together any other
way Irish in the north who were never
great fans of the British Empire
combined with southerners in the in the
ex Confederacy who'd never forgiven the
British Empire for probably the real
reason the British Empire fell which was
it failed to support the south against
the north
in the Civil War and that would have
that would have divided the United
States so in that sense Abraham Lincoln
not Franklin Roosevelt destroyed the
British Empire
and he does he destroyed it very
cleverly with the Emancipation
Proclamation which made it politically
impossible for Britain to to intervene
but listen I mean here we we murdered
the fairest and finest empire ever known
but we picked its eyes out in its hour
of greatest need is the American Empire
if that's what it is is it a good thing
it could be I certainly want it to be it
seems to me clear that one lesson of the
British experience is that though the
British Empire did many things wrong by
the time it had become a liberal Empire
in the 19th and the first half of the
20th centuries it had clearly become a
force for good in the world that's to
say when we look at the things that the
British Empire systematically did from
let us say the 1820s or 1830s until it
was finally broken up in the 1950s the
key things that stand out are the
prioritization of economic openness free
trade free capital movements free
migration call it if you like a kind of
Victorian vision of globalization but it
also stood not just for for free markets
it also stood for a certain kind of
institution a certain complex of
institutions which in a fascinating way
development economists in the last 10 or
so years in this country have
rediscovered if you read any of the
really interesting and important books
and papers published in the last 10
years by some of the great economists
working in this country today I think of
Robert barro I think of my colleague at
NYU will you be still a tastic critique
of development economics is one of the
most readable books in the shops at the
moment they argue clearly and
consistently that economic growth in
relatively poor countries requires not
only the openness that Jeff Sachs and
others emphasized in the 90s but it also
requires certain key institutional
structures it needs the rule of law it
needs to have non corrupt administration
and politics these are crucial property
rights underpinned particularly by
common law definitions of property
rights are crucial for the functioning
of a market economy and without that I
mean without the rule of law civil
society - can't really flourish now
there's a fantastic body of literature
and all this which I've spent much of my
time reading because Empire is an
attempt to integrate that literature
with the history of the nineteenth
century and when you read it through
check off the things that contemporary
economists advise developing economies
to do balanced budgets stable currency
avoid inflation read through the list
and you find that these are precisely
the things that British colonial
administrators set out to do they
essentially set out to create a
globalized world economy and to build
the institutions within which poor
countries could aspire to success within
that global economy and I try to show in
the book that this really works that it
really did deliver in the clear majority
of British colonies economic growth not
only that but most countries a clear
majority of those that then relinquished
British rule subsequently fared worse
economically under the various forms of
Nationalist government that they adopted
and it's not surprising why because what
you find if you take sub-saharan Africa
is that nearly every former colony
pretty quickly slipped into institutions
calculated to kill economic growth
inflationary fiscal policies debauched
currencies corrupt civil services and
political elites and the systematic
undermining of the rule of law if the
name of Robert Mugabe hasn't already
sprung to mind by this point it
certainly should have in the supreme
irony is that a man like Mugabe loves to
blame is in Babli's problems on the
legacy of Empire the dirty secret about
decolonization this is another thing
that dare not speak its name
is that most of the economic failures of
sub-saharan Africa have been due to
independence not a British imperial
and the cost has been high indeed I cite
just one example neighboring Zambia the
end of British rule in 1960 per-capita
GDP in Britain was about seven times
that of Zambia so the gap was of the
order of magnitude of seven times today
it's more like 28 times because Zambia's
economy has not just stagnated it has
positively declined under independence
and it's one of a host of examples one
could cite virtually there in the
African country not to have this
experience as Botswana
ergo it can work a liberal Anglophone
empire which is committed to economic
openness to creating the institutions
that promote growth to creating the rule
of law to establishing civil society
this can achieve what I'd take to be
America's sincere objective to export
its success story to the rest of the
world right now it's not happening if
you compare capital flows to poor
countries today with capital flows to
equivalently poor countries 100 years
ago the discrepancy is truly astonishing
back in the days of British hegemony
something like 20 to 25 percent of
international capital flows went to
countries which had a per capita income
of 20 percent or less of the United
States today countries comparably poor
receive around five or percent or less
of international capital flows why it's
obvious because poor countries today are
by and large governed by their own
corrupt ah
now what would Keynes have done at a
moment like this I'm more tolerant I'm
more tolerant than Keynes and less
clever than Keynes so I will I will
forgive the the ringing phone and just
and just say to myself blue sessions
Purcell mm sure
I always take the opportunity to use
French and American company these days
all right well thank you Neil and and we
appreciate the tact that led you not to
mention that one of the countries which
had economic disaster after
decolonization was the United States
under the Articles of Confederation when
we had debauched currency failure of
rule of law and so on and so forth the
US is interesting it's one of the tiny
number of post colonies that actually
fared better under independent
institutions and the reason for that's
pretty clear that the institutions were
pretty much in place by the time the
United States became independent you've
done with us what you see now you know
why they say timeo danaos at libros
parentis I fear the Greeks bearing books
because apparently the policy
prescription for all of us is that we
should clamor to get back in but enough
you know as much fun as we're having up
here it's actually time to open this up
to questions from the floor so we will
do that now please wait when you're
called on for the microphone to get to
there so everyone can hear you and also
please state your name and affiliation
before you begin your question keep your
questions short make them questions not
statements even in the United States I
think we've learned that much grammar
English grammar so that others can as
many people as possible can get a chance
to respond yes
and inna Gorski Newsweek I'd like to
really restate the question Walter asked
and I don't think you responded to is
what's the benefit even if one accepts
your thesis of declaring ourselves an
empire at this point and how would it be
received in today's world well let me
make clear that I don't actually
advocate a declaration and I think
everybody in this room knows exactly
what the effect of that would be in some
senses it's redundant though it's
redundant because most of America's
critics already consider it an empire
therefore a declaration would merely
confirm what they already know and the
biggest problem would be that it would
greatly alarm American voters who
continue to bask in the illusion that
there are countries vast overseas
military commitments and economic
engagements and regular military
interventions are in some strange way
the actions of a non Empire you see I
don't really care what the United States
calls this for a long time people who
study international relations in this
country have used the word hegemony us
something about Greeks seems to appeal
to Americans in this particular line but
it's a euphemism it is a euphemism
Empire can only be excluded as a
definition of American par today if the
if if one uses up the word in a very
narrow sense and I think anybody who
seriously thinks about empire would look
at the structures of American global
power look at the deployments of troops
look at the dependencies I counted them
today I make it 16 look at the expansion
of American economic and military power
and say if this isn't an empire then the
word has no meaning so there's no need
to declare it the question is to
recognize that it exists and that with
Empire comes responsibility now the most
important point of all about recognizing
not proclaiming from the rooftops
please don't get me wrong the idea of
President Bush going on on national
television and announcing that
Republic is now an empire I mean really
shades of a kind of carry on film on
ancient Rome the Republic mustn't ever
call itself an empire because it is it's
a republic and we all know what happens
to Republic's that proclaim themselves
to be empires there there are lessons
from Roman history which I think non
Greeks could perhaps Terr usefully
remind you of now the key thing is to
recognize privately amongst yourselves
that this is the situation and that
therefore certain things follow from
that for example it is not an option to
send in the Marines and the 82nd
airborne overthrow sit down the same
pull down the statues fire off some
hardware hold elections and come home
these sorts of sporadic interventions
which always make me think of one of
those cartoons in which a boy opens a
box an enormous boxing glove comes out
on a spring this is not how you run an
empire at the moment the United States
has arrived as a form of empire which
seems to be almost exclusively military
only the Defense Department seems to
recognize that it's an empire and it
does its side of the operation
tremendously well the lessons have been
learned both the level of strategy and
at the level of tactics and operations
and they've been learnt brilliantly but
the problem is that the follow-through
seems almost consistently to be absent
why is that why is it that in
Afghanistan so little so far has been
achieved following the overthrow of the
Taliban regime why is it that one can
already sense what I would call the
Haiti on the Tigris scenario in in
Baghdad a sense that having achieved the
military objective the United States
really doesn't know quite how to go on
to the next crucial step the next
crucial step is to get the Iraqi economy
to function and that is a highly complex
undertaking and former generals are
probably the least qualified people to
do this because there are a few groups
of people more cut off from the free
market and its workings than people who
operate within the US military
they're almost uniquely ill qualified to
construct a functioning market economy
in the ruins of a totalitarian regime
people often forget that in 1945 after
was 3-4 years of total war the US
military was full of highly skilled
specialists academics and professionals
it was not a professional army itself so
that when the reconstruction of West
Germany and Japan occurred the two most
successful achievements of the American
Empire to date all kinds of expertise
was available in uniform to undertake
that job now I asked a question in the
New York Times to which I've yet to hear
a satisfactory answer it was to put it
very crudely where are the Gertrude
bells I could equally well have said
where are the Galbraith's today where
are the people who are willing to go to
a country like Iraq and construct from
the bottom are the functioning
institutions of a markers the
institutional basis for civil society
above all else the institutions of the
rule of law where are they and the
answer is you don't really produce them
and this is a fundamental problem to
produce the most effective military
force in the world and not to produce
any kind of counterpart to the British
colonial service or the Indian civil
service that elite of non corrupt
officials who so Abele constructed the
civil society that was central to the
success of British imperial operations
this is a near fatal omission so the
answer to the question is and I hope
that it's a satisfactory answer to you
recognizing that America and is an
empire means recognizing that it is more
than simply a military project that it
requires long-term commitment of
resources not just financial resources
but Talent in order to make regime
change work and if you're not prepared
to do that if there is no intention to
spend years transforming Iraq into a
functioning society not a not a
westernized society
leave its culture alone for heaven's
sake but a society which has the basic
institutions in which the market can
function property rights are protected
and some kind of civil society can can
develop yeah well can I just follow that
up with one punch line please this will
benefit the United States this is not
going to be some kind of zero-sum game
in which every dollar spent on the
reconstruction of Iraq is a dollar less
for American schools and hospitals a
growing dynamic Iraqi economy which I
believe is an attainable objective will
be a source of prosperity and employment
for Americans the idea that the Empire
was ever a great millstone around
Britain's neck is one that needs to be
Scotch
it clearly wasn't and I would happily
debate the economic arguments with you
if there were time but the key point is
to recognize that for the United States
making these countries safe is a
economically advisable be it will reduce
your long-term security costs and the
long-term threat to the United States
from terror but to intervene militarily
and to take the Haiti approach first the
guns then the elections then go home is
a recipe for even worse states than
existed before ok that's that's great
please let's all try to be as laconic as
possible you talking to me Oh
just want to get as many questions as
possible yeah I heard yes right here you
yes bring a microphone in Ferguson with
Forbes if the new Chinese Empire as
another recent book just entitles it
survives its current crises do you see
any parallels to the early 20th century
German challenge to Britain it's
conceivable it's an interesting
literature at the moment and I've spent
a lot of time reading it recently the
who's the next big threat literature and
it seems to divide fairly evenly between
people who worried about China and the
people who worry about Europe thinking
of Charles cook Chan for example I find
it much harder as a European to see a
long-term strategic threat from the
European Union which kind of leaves
China China is a long long way behind
militarily economically in all kinds of
fundamental ways it's institutionally
got disadvantages which I'm not
convinced it can overcome to put it very
simply the jury is still out on the
question can you have a transition to a
market economy and retain the
institutions of one-party rule and I
said before the Economist said is that
SARS might just be the Chernobyl moment
when the tension between these two
different structures between economic
freedom and political unfreedom starts
to become unsustainable now if you
project forward Chinese growth rates as
some people do and I've tried this
exercise to amuse myself you can you can
arrive at the conclusion that in the
year 2018 the Chinese economy in terms
of gross domestic product will be the
same size as if not bigger than the
American economy even if you project
forward American growth rates as they've
been quite high growth rates for the
last 20 years is that really going to
happen I have my doubts you know much of
the argument about China tends to be
demographic look how many Chinese there
are imagine if they were all suddenly
rich but you know
let me ask a different question a
demographic question if one looks at
birth rates around the world the Chinese
growth rates not especially high the
highest birth rates in the world are
almost exclusively in Muslim countries
and it's almost double actually the
global average and if one looks at the
Muslim population of the world and does
a little projection to me the possible
explosion of Muslim populations poses a
much more profound challenge to American
hegemony than the possible growth of the
Chinese economy now that's not to say
that I subscribe to the Huntington view
that there's a clash of civilizations in
the offing because we know that these
Muslim populations come from many
different cultures and we know that it's
perfectly possible and indeed Fareed
Zakaria argued recently convincingly
it's perfectly possible for an Islamic
society to make the transition to
democracy but I do think that might be a
bigger story than the the much vaunted
Chinese takeover militarily there's a
long way to go before they're anything
other than a sort of really big version
of North Korea yes in the back game set
record arrows you referred to the
successful US actions in Japan after
World War two the professor from MIT
who's written a classic book on that
subject John dower
recently cautioned America against
comparing the Japanese occupation with
anything that would happen in Iraq for a
lot of reasons including the security
that an island provided the fact that
there was not a single terrorist
incident against America's 250,000
troops during the six years Nate year
six years and eight months of operation
the ethnic identity of the China the
Japanese versus that the difference does
in in Iraq could you please comment on
what you think about mr. Dhar thesis oh
no one knows more about the subject than
da and I think his work not only on the
occupation but on the Pacific Wars is
some of the most important work to come
out of the American historical
profession in recent years when I
certainly I'm going to
presume to criticize his analysis of the
success of the Japanese occupation the
lesson seems to me actually to be more
readily drawn from the West German
experience now clearly the ethnic
arguments don't work quite so well there
though remember that West Germany was a
country in turmoil with vast numbers of
refugees flooding into it from Eastern
Europe and admittedly the great majority
of them were Germans but there were
Germans from very different parts of
Europe that wasn't really the principal
challenge the principal challenge was
the complete destruction of the German
economy both by aerial bombardment and
by the dictatorship itself which had
systematically wrecked the market
economy corrupted the rule of law almost
entirely and I think creatives in the
end the worst rogue regime in history
now if one looks at Germany in 1945 with
the benefit of hindsight it's easy to
say it was bound to bounce back they
were Germans after all and this is an
argument I constantly hear and I say you
know that's very interesting you should
say that because that's exactly what
people said in 1918 Oh Jeremy is bound
to bounce back there are Germans after
all indeed many many Americans invested
tens thousands hundreds of thousands of
dollars in the Germany of the 1920s and
lost every single cent there was no
guarantee that Germany was going to be a
success after 1945 and of course going
back to your point about borders West
Germany was in an extraordinarily
vulnerable strategic position with all
kinds of historic conflicts to the east
and to the west threatening at any point
to boil over to resume I think the
better parallel is actually with the
colossal success of Congress of the of
the office of military government u.s.
and in West Germany in transforming what
was a ruined economy but not only a
ruined economy but a profoundly
corrupted society never underestimate
how easy it is to wreck civil society in
the rule of law Michael Bernal is
wonderful book on the Third Reich which
I recommend you all read
shows how profound the cultural
revolution was it was not by any means a
foregone conclusion that Germany would
morph back into a liberal society if it
had ever been won before and that in
itself is contentious but one key thing
stands out why I did West Germany
recovery economically and then socially
and then politically the answer is the
Marshall Plan at least in some measure
kick-started an economic recovery in
Germany which was to be the wonder of
the post-war world if there's a lesson
to be learned from the experience of
occupation in 1945 is that you can do
wonders with some pump priming and a
currency reform and if that's a better
analogy it's it's convenient for me
because it's the one I know more about
but it seems to me to work much better
than the Japanese story from for the
reasons that you yourself state yes
ma'am
Norma globerman
X UNDP I would I would hope that you
would hypothesize on this question if
the actions of the United States after
World War two
in effect cost Britain its empire and if
going to war if if Britain's going to
part against Germany and needing the
United States to come out of the war
successful cost it its empire what would
have happened if it had reached an
accommodation with Germany and not going
to war in terms of what would have
happened then to the British Empire and
is anyone hypothesizing about this well
actually quite a number of people have
posed that counterfactual question
including I think I'm right in saying
puppy cannon that well-known well-known
American scholar Alan Clark the late
lamented I'm trying to think of the
right term biron of the Conservative
Party also made this argument and he
based it on John Charlie's work clearly
there was a possibility to reach an
accommodation with Hitler because the
Germans offered it and a majority of of
Churchill's cabinet colleagues favoured
it he was reckless in the reckless
minority who thought it was worth
fighting on after the fall of France and
I can answer this question very simply
and I'm going to in order to maximize
the number of questions I can take it
would have been a calamity of world
historical proportions unimaginable
disaster would have ensued and we should
all I think thank God at least once a
month that Churchill prevailed and that
Britain against all if you like logic
fought on alone against the most evil
dictatorship of all time and disbelieved
Hitler's lies because Hitler was lying
and I show in the book actually how much
Hitler sucked up to the British he loved
saying how wonderful the British Empire
was and he loved telling everybody how
he much
at martyrs and how much he wished to
learn from this and apply the lessons of
the Raj in in the Ukraine which he
signally did not do it was a lie because
we know from Hitler's war planning in
the 1930s that the next step after
European dominance was the Atlantic and
indeed the next step would have been the
United States fortunately fortunately
for the United States one thing stood
between Nazi Germany and world
domination that was the British Empire
and if the British Empire hadn't existed
if the proponents of decolonization had
been heeded at any time since a 1857 and
Britain alone the United Kingdom alone
had stood against Nazi Germany then
Hitler would have won the war yes you hi
I'm Zachary karabell and you're a Fred
Alger management if the United States if
I'm a question about first principles if
Empire is not the acquisition of direct
rule of territory and imperialism is not
the search to directly acquire territory
then what are those things and if the
United States clearly can go into Iraq
or Afghanistan and leave and no one can
prevent us from doing either of those
things then wouldn't it be more accurate
to say that we have the capacity for
empire and not the will for it and then
without the will for it or not
well I think that's a perfectly
legitimate question but you seem to be
assuming that the United States has not
in the past acquired territory it's
quite impossible to imagine any of the
operations that we've witnessed you know
that's the supreme irony but I think my
telephone is good
but you know what they say when in Rome
do as the Romans do oh and for John
Maynard Keynes well you know what Keynes
used to say when the facts change I
changed my opinions what do you see to
try and resume as best I can almost
impossible to recover from that I think
it's only the second time in my life
it's ever happened it once happened
during a performance of elektra zoë
Wanamaker was in the midst of a
monologue of really breathtaking power
and a ghastly noise interrupted it
that's my phone
I thought I'd learned my lesson but it
only proves that that's why you had to
come here right yeah it was run out of
run I've never been to a theatre since
in London but the point that you seem to
I think omit is that the United States
is military capability entirely depends
on the control of territory the military
base is the network of military bases
that that extends around the globe the
bases that have been accumulated
systematically since the 1890s which
were substantially added to at the end
of the Second World War and which
continue to be indispensable for the
exercise of Imperial par but territory
matters less now it matters less it's
not irrelevant that it matters less than
it did in the days of the Roman empires
it matters less not least because like
the British Empire the American Empire
can rely on its dominance of the Seas in
order to exert global power an awful lot
of the American Empire floats this is a
floating and flying Empire and it was
never possible really before the British
Empire in 18th century to construct an
empire on the basis of flirtation much
less flight in that sense I think the
American Empire is an empire despite the
fact that its territorial extent is
currently roughly half slightly more
than half of the territorial extent of
the British Empire at its zenith you
might be surprised to realize that the
American Empire is already so big but it
is and it's just a fallacy it seems to
me to say owner that doesn't count
because
most of that landmass is the United
States the United States is in itself an
empire let me put it to you that you
could write America's history as follows
the construction of an empire by the 13
colonies former colonies of the eastern
seaboard and their empire is very
tightly knit Empire it's been much more
tightly integrated colonies like
California and Texas consider themselves
far closer to the metropolis than any
colonies of the British Empire did
you've got one very big Ireland if you
like to think of it that way in the end
in the end it seems to me the analogy
holds good and this is a huge
territorial Empire that you are
currently running and although most of
the territories within the political
boards of the United States quite a lot
of it isn't okay yes I'm Dan sharp with
the Royal Institution world science
assembly I gather from our title that
our object is to see what we can learn
from the British Empire that might help
us particularly in Iraq and I'm a bit
puzzled about what lesson we derive from
your comments you've criticized rather
roundly our approach to building
institutions in Iraq and so I reflect on
your comments extolling the virtues of
the British colonial office and the
decades of time that you had to build
those institutions and your colonies and
then you told us it was a complete
failure that after independence
everything went bad what are the lessons
we should derive from the British Empire
experience for how we manage wreck it's
quite a relief that somebody's finally
asked the question I'm rather at the
mercy of my interlocutors this evening
the
the answer is that of course if you look
at the persistence of democracy after
decolonization it's still more likely to
have taken in former British colonies
than than elsewhere being governed by
the British was clearly better for the
chances of democratization being
governed by anybody else and that of
course is one very good reason why India
1 billion Indians would have to be
American well I'm not I'm not sure
whether the American example is helpful
here but but let's let's put put America
to one side because the democracy
persisted here remarkably well
even after decolonization the big
question is how you can learn from
Britain's relative lack of success in
the Middle East
now remember 41 years of formal and
informal control was not a long time by
the standards of the British Empire
you count up the duration of Imperial
presence in say the Caribbean in other
parts of Asia a hundred years plus was
the norm and so one very simple lesson
that one could learn from Britain's
experience in the Middle East might be
that if you really expect to transform
the institutions of a society like Iraq
it's a very very long and time-consuming
process and one must be realistic about
that there is no necessary reason why
the institutions of the rule of law of
civil society should just pop up out of
the soil by themselves after all they
took long enough to take form even in
Western Europe
the second lesson I would draw and this
is an extremely important one that I've
come to understand better since being
here is that coordination between the
military economic and civil agencies of
Empire is crucial and what is woefully
absent in Washington DC today is any
serious coordination between the Defense
Department State Department the
International Monetary Fund the World
Bank which effectively is boycotting
this operation as far as I can
understand an absence of coordination
which to British eyes is completely
baffling 100 years ago
a little further back let's go to 1882
in 1882 the British invaded Egypt and
they did so to avert a debt default and
they did it in very much the spirit
actually of the occupation of Iraq today
that is to say they claimed they weren't
going to stay in fact between I think it
was 82 and 1922 they promised the
international community they would leave
Egypt 66 times which I think must be
some kind of record for diplomatic Monde
acity and they then set about creating
the institutions which they thought
Egypt needed public finance was
anglicized completely under the benign
despotism of lord cromer a product of
the barring banking family now what is
really striking about the Egyptian
operation the longest and I think most
successful of Britain's middle-eastern
operations is the brilliant coordination
between the financiers the civil
authorities and the military and the
very careful way in which the military
was kept in check the Kitchener a Sardar
of Egypt was a formidable figure a very
dangerous figure with ambitions that
were falling far in excess of the
conventional British general but he was
never allowed to dominate Cromer now I
think the lesson that really needs to be
learned here is that if you embark an
imperial project there needs to be close
cooperation close cooperation between
the military and civilian authorities
and the civilian authorities need to
dominate there is nothing in my mind
more dangerous historically than an
empire dominated by the generals the
lessons of Rome are very very clear in
this regard and you as a Republic need
to take those lessons to heart there is
a very very strong sense and one gets it
constantly that this is an empire an
empire built by Imperial Pro consuls
whose training is a military training
people who are trained by the US
military may not be as respectful of the
liberties that you as non military men
and women hold dear as you assume it
would be very surprising in the history
of mankind if they were that seems to me
to be the biggest and most important
lesson
my book has to offer the American Empire
but listen this has really been a
terrific session I know we all want to
thank Neil for sharing these thoughts
this much advice
this is the last meeting that I'm
scheduled to preside over while les Gelb
is President of the Council on Foreign
Relations and while he isn't couldn't be
here tonight he very much wanted to be
but could not be I don't think it'd be
appropriate for me to close an occasion
like this without just saying how much I
appreciate what les has done for the
council and for me during the next
couple of months we'll all have I think
a number of chances to to say something
to him personally and institutionally
and in various ways but I think you'd
all want to join me in in thanking les
for making the council the kind of place
it is today
Neil Ferguson is currently a financial
history professor at NYU Stern School of
Business Empire is published by basic
books on the web at basic books calm
next week on history on book TV iris
Chang traces the immigration of Chinese
people to the US if you're interested in
finding out about the authors and books
featured on history on book TV